hey ich hab euch mal wieder auf
instagram gesagt dass sie mir bitte
einige fragen stellen sollten dann habt
ihr zahlreich getan von daher würde ich
sagen haben wir mit der ersten frage du
siehst aus wie ein stock parisi
vergammeltes gemüse schon mal
aufgefallen danke hat man direkt bock
auf das video welche farbe haben
schlümpfe wenn man sie wirkt keine
ahnung dicker
die sind blau also würde ich sagen
grünen schmeißt seine kissen in müll
wird sandra ich glaube du hast den sinn
von fragen nicht so richtig verstanden
kannst du laufen
nein stinkt sandra echt so ja muss ich
wirklich ganz klar so beantworten immer
wenn sandra zumindest im sommer hier
hinkommen geht sie als allererstes in
eine dusche und wäscht sich ihre füße
und das war auch gestern der fall weil
gestern war sondern zum letzten mal hier
[Musik]
und noch eine kleine side story dazu
salate heute eine pediküre termin und
die dame die ihre füße halt lackiert hat
und keine ahnung was hat dir dann auch
ein schutz spray gegeben
gegen geruch ihrer füße also ja sandra
stinkt wirklich so krass ich war gestern
sehr tief tauchen habe der niveau aber
leider nicht gefunden sorry auch du hast
den sinn von fragen nicht verstand aber
trotzdem danke dass du mir bei der suche
eines niveaus helfen wollte ist wenn wir
im märz sind schwimmen wir doch in fisch
pilze oder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fischer eigentlich müssen sie überhaupt
wissen ich war noch nie gut in bio was
für musikrichtungen hörst du alles ich
weiß dass das immer so die pillow
antwort ist wenn man sagt hey was dein
lieblings liefert hören wir für musik
ich war alles so dass es mal so von
wegen ja der hat keine lieblingsmusik
erkennt sie überhaupt nicht aus aber ich
höre techno zum beispiel beim autofahren
nicht hip hop immer wenn ich in der
stadt bin ich zum beispiel wenn ich
dusche ich habe podcasts manchmal wenn
ich im bahn sitze also ganz
unterschiedlich bei mir wie sieht deine
traumfrau aus ehrlich gesagt habe ich
gar keine 1a traumfrau und so soll sie
aussehen sondern es kommt komplett aufs
gesamtpaket an also da kann sie gerne
blond sein oder braun harry oder
schwarzhaarig oder rotary oder keine
ahnung was oder irgendwie so und so
solange das gesamtpaket gegen gestimmt
ist alles cool wie würde das perfekte
leben für dich aussehen ich finde
ehrlich gesagt dass mein leben gerade
schon nahezu perfekt ist ich habe eine
wunderbare familie die mich über alles
nicht und die ich auch über alles liebe
ich habe wunderbare freunde ich habe
keine freunde aber real tor patrick also
ich finde mein leben grenz gerade schon
nahmen die perfektion das soll jetzt
nicht arrogant klingen oder keine ahnung
was habe ich bin wirklich sehr sehr froh
gerade darüber wo ich im lebensstil wie
ich im leben stehe und mit welchen
leuten nicht dort stehe positiv was ist
die einzel von eltern elternteil hat
luca de - was ist die mehrzahl von
mehrzahl mehrzahl lugano - in dein
größter fan du antwortest rené ich das
war zwar auch keine frage aber hier
meine antwort
marlena kannst dir grüße würdest du ein
video mit katja machen kannst du mich
grüßen heiße sabine also erstmal sabina
ganz ganz ganz ganz liebe grüße hier von
mir
luca und wer auch sonst und zum thema
katja ja wir haben sich tatsächlich mal
angefragt für eine podcast folge
einerseits über ihr management also
wirklich den direkten business weg
andererseits aber auch über freunde dass
sie niemals fragen aber beide male
abgelehnt
also sie hatte anscheinend nicht so
interesse daran ich würde feiern ich
finde auf jeden fall witzig aber ich
glaube von ihr aus besteht gar kein
interesse deine lieblings automarke
porsche ganz klar mit der riesigen
historie und gerade auch was rennsport
angeht finde ich ist es einfach die
kompletteste automarke auf der welt was
ist dein ziel für die nächsten jahre
ehrlich gesagt habe ich gar kein
übergeordnetes ziel was ich jetzt
langfristig erreichen will
ich lebe gerade finanziell unabhängig
also ich verdiene genug geld um mir mein
leben gerade zu ermöglichen so wie es
leben möchte und ich habe tolle freunde
und eine tolle familie und poly
positiven vibes sollte man dem ist es
nicht peinlich wenn du dein video
bearbeitet und eine stimme hörst ehrlich
gesagt mittlerweile nicht mehr und ich
bin ganz ehrlich mir war meine stimme
auch ehrlich gesagt noch nie so richtig
peinlich und vor allem durch diese ganze
sprachnachrichten kultur auf whatsapp
und instagram das ist ja alles von paar
jahren angefangen mit denen mit den
ganzen sprachnachrichten und so glaube
ich dass ein selbst auch die eigene
stimme gar nicht mehr so krass ab fax
wie es früher der fall war
dabei sind doch freunde familie meint
immer nur so macht das video aus lucka
wo ich da im hintergrund zu hören wenn
er ganz schlimm eine stimme wie tief
seine führerscheinprüfung theorie 0
fehlerpunkte und praxis auch der alm
also real talk ich liebe autofahren ich
habe mich darauf sehr lange vorbereitet
ich wollte unbedingt so schnell es geht
irgendwie meinen führerschein machen und
ja auch alles ganz gut geklappt und bin
auch bisher unfallfrei gewesen
dreimal auf holz klopfen magst du
porridge ja ich glaube die lisa hier hat
meine instagram story vor einigen tagen
sich angeschaut und 2
da gedanken das war vorgestern glaube
ich und ich habe es mir ehrlich gesagt
nur gemacht weil es halt im angebot war
beim rewe lieferservice und dann hab ich
mir halt auch noch porridge mitbestellt
und noch so einige freunde heidelbeeren
mixes und shazam und solist ist wirklich
lecker hätte ich nicht gedacht weil ich
bin auch bei diesen ganzen blogger food
sachen immer ganz vorsichtig auch so
broke about so gar nicht meinen dingen
diese ganzen sachen aber porridge mega
da ist es schmeckt quasi einfach wie
milchreis kann ich auch mal in einem
video vorkommen edu wird leider nichts
wenn du eine frucht wärs welche wärst du
pizza humor aufwies bestellt ist sie gut
findet dich so sympathisch erstmal
dankeschön fürs kompliment amélie und ja
wir jetzt gerade definitiv gut also wie
bereits schon mehrmals gesagt ich habe
tolle leute um mich rum ich habe eine
tolle familie tolle freunde ich fühle
mich gerade wohl in köln und jetzt
nochmal mit dem umzug nach hamburg ich
weiß ich werde zwar denke ich nie so
richtig in hamburg sein sondern immer
gefühlt nur in köln bleiben aber ja mir
geht es auf jeden fall sehr gut gerade
dankeschön es gibt wirklich nichts
schöneres als leute die einen fragen auf
seinem gut geht finde ich weiß halt die
leute kümmern sich um ein und wollen so
wisst ihr wie ich meinen aber gut geht's
weiter mit dieser frage meine freunde in
welchem alter möchtest du dein erstes
kind keine ahnung wenn es soweit ist
dann ist es soweit wenn ich mich so weit
fühle dann fühle ich mich so weit aber
stand jetzt kann ich mir zumindest jetzt
gerade noch gar kein kind in meinem
leben vorstellen reis oder nudeln wenn
ich mich entscheiden müsste dann reißt
aber ich finde beides ziemlich geil wie
viel kostet eine wohnung in köln im
monat 0 euro also ich habe direkt
gekauft deswegen zahlen quasi keine
miete und auch die wohnung in hamburg
habe ich gekauft also dort werde ich
auch keine miete zahlen also ja sie
kostet nix wenn ich sie mieten würde
weiß ich nicht 3000 eur 4.000 euro oder
so um den dreh glaube ich bist du auf
der suche nach einer beziehung nein ich
suche gerade nicht aktiv eine beziehung
also ist jetzt nicht so dass ich mir
denke wow ich fühle mich irgendwie grade
von einsamen ich hatte gerade folge eine
beziehung oder keine ahnung was so ich
möchte einfach mein leben leben und wenn
irgendwas kommt dann kommt was unter
nichts kommt dann kommt es nicht und ich
bin hier francesca also fall wie ist es
eigentlich so mit sandra befreundet zu
sein und wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt
also mit sandra befreundet zu sein
ganz normal wie mit einem anderen
menschen halt auch befreundet zu sein
sondern ganz normale freundschaft und
die haben uns kennengelernt weil sie in
den pool meiner eltern für jedes 12
abzeichen trainiert hat und sie das weiß
auch ganz genau sandra musste irgendwie
eine bestimmte anzahl an minuten am
stück schwimmen und irgendwie haben
bestimmt minutenzahl hat man nicht mehr
ihre füße gesehen sondern nur ihre hände
mit den füßen wurden gelaufen für uns so
getan als würde sie schwimmen haben wir
denn deine wohnung ziehen wenn du in
hamburg wohnen ist ja klar safe sie
einen gar kein problem welche eurer
podcast folgen feierst du am meisten
wären als wenn du mich grüßt in klammern
helly also erstmal haley ganz ganz ganz
ganz liebe grüße von mir von luca warum
soll ich das mal von mir ist auch klar
dass das von mir kommt aber welche
partners folge falscher meisten das
technisch schwierige frage ich finde
viele folgen cool so richtig jetzt auf
marketing angelehnt jede folge ist als
müsste unbedingt anhören spotify laut
und lästig und du meine lieblings folge
sind glaube ich die bier testing folgen
haben ja vor einer woche auch eine neue
folge online zeit immer lustig weil wir
halt was neues ausprobieren wir trinken
bisschen was uns und die finde ich ganz
ganz unterhaltsam hast du mal einen
promi getroffen also ich weiss nicht ab
wann man sagt das ist jetzt ein
richtiger promi oder keine ahnung was
aber die krasseste person finde ich
bisher treffen durfte war cristiano
ronaldo ich auch ein foto von auf
instagram gepostet also das war wirklich
krass war zwar nur eine minute oder so
kurz unterhalten aber das war echt
heftig wie läuft's mitschüler nicht so
gut wie left me on ried ladies and
gentlemen meinung zur freundschaft plus
ich finde wenn beide leute damit okay
sind
rinat findest du die bundesliga
langweilig weil bayern immer meister
wird also ich bin ja schon länger nicht
mehr richtiger bayern-fan das weicher
als kind wegen bastian schweinsteiger
weil ich den ja so cool fand allerdings
seitdem ich jetzt in köln wohnen ist man
einfach automatisch fc köln fan weil die
stadt einfach so patriotisch ist und
keine ahnung was und wenn man köln fan
ist dann interessiert einen diese
meisterschaft sache da oben gar nicht
sondern kümmert sich halt nur um den
verein setzen und den abstieg oder halt
vielleicht mal wieder um die europa
league aber ich finde eigentlich sehr
interessant warum bist du mit sandra
zusammen wtf habe ich was verpasst fake
friends erfahrungen wie bist du damit
umgegangen ehrlich gesagt einfach
abschießen solche leute einfach generell
menschen die sich nicht für dich
interessieren sondern irgendwie von dem
profitieren wollen
was denkst du über die korona waren app
finde ich sehr gut und finde ich auch
richtig und wichtig damit wir bald
wieder normales leben findet ich kann es
nicht nachvollziehen das ist wirklich so
viele freimaurer gibt sie jetzt sagen
über die bundesregierung sammelt daten
über uns und spioniert uns aus so leute
man kann den quellcode öffentlich
einsehen von der app ihr seht ganz genau
was da irgendwie programmiert ist und
was nicht und trotzdem und instagram was
wir täglich stundenlang nutzen ist viel
viel schlimmer
also ich finde es sehr sehr sehr sehr
gut hast du schon mal die unterschrift
seiner eltern gefälscht
in der dritten klasse mit acht oder neun
jahren habe es aber am ende des
schuljahres mit meiner mutter meiner
klassenlehrerin gebeichtet und nicht
verkratzt dafür gelobt weil sie meinte
ich sei sehr ehrlich und sie wisse auch
von mehreren schülern dass sie auch die
unterschriften fälschen die haben es
nicht gebeichtet dass ich bin leider was
so straftaten angeht viel zu ehrlicher
mensch kannst du gut kochen und wäsche
waschen bügeln also wäsche waschen kann
ich aber kochen nicht so gut und bügeln
auch nicht ich habe mich früher zehn mal
an einem bügeleisen verbrannt pro woche
das war echt ziemlich schmerzhaft
allerdings würde ich auf der stelle das
heutige wir jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn ihr auch fragen
haben ich habe dann folgte auf instagram
dann verpasste die nächste fragerunde
mit luca auf jeden fall nicht wenn euch
das video gefallen hat alles gerne einen
daumenbruch unter dem video hier und
jetzt befinden es auch schon im auto
meine lieben freunde werden noch kein
abonnent von meinem kanal sei dann
klickt mal ganz schnell wieder obenauf
den smiley drauf ist ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr und wenn die
letzte fragerunde mit luca verpasst
haben sollte dann klickt jetzt hier
drauf dann könnt ihr euch das noch mal
anschauen dann beantworte ich noch
andere fragen zum thema beziehungen
unter anderem und auch zusammen
harmoniert man channel und ich bin